This is exclusive video of Elon giving a lecture
at his home in Bel-Air.
Is everybody listening?
He didn't think regular schools were doing
a good enough job of preparing kids.
He’s a big proponent of teaching people
to think based on First Principles, which
is figuring out how things work by boiling
them down to the basics.
For example, it used to be that people thought
a radical improvement in rocketry was impossible.
Space agencies and private companies tried
to build reusable rockets but failed.
The only one that “kind of” worked was
NASA’s space shuttle - but the cost of refurbishing
the boosters by fishing them out of the ocean
was so great that it didn’t make sense.
You look at what others are doing.
And say, ‘Well, others didn’t make it
work, so therefore it doesn’t work.’
That has no basis in reality.
A first principles foundational approach would
be to say, ‘Let’s look at the physics
and economics of a rocket,’ and say, ‘If
we can analyze the physics of the rocket,
is it physically possible?’
First principles thinking would break down
the cost of the rocket’s materials and figure
out how to reassemble the materials to produce
a more affordable rocket…which is SpaceX’s
mission.
Ad Astra school originally began out of SpaceX’s
rocket facility in Hawthorne, California,
to teach Elon’s own children and the kids
of some employees.
Then it moved to his house for a couple of
years, the one that formerly belonged to Gene
Wilder.
Elon was a guest lecturer.
The teacher who helped create the curriculum
was Josh Dahn.
Hi Josh
Hi Cindy
Dahn taught one of Elon’s sons at a private
school for gifted children in LA.
The SpaceX CEO then approached him to start
an experimental school at his rocket factory.
If Elon’s directive was to make the school
great.
Okay, what does great look like?
It looked like a totally different experience
than a typical school.
Instead of classes in languages, music, or
sports, kids focused on critical thinking,
solving the types of problems SpaceX employees
tackle.
Imagine how the grid fin can be redesigned.
He’s referring to the fins that come down
when the Falcon 9 lands.
Could you imagine other designs and how would
you know if those designs would be more efficacious
than the designs that are currently being
used.
The lesson of first principles is to not be
bound by what’s already been done.
You don’t have to create grid fins of the
same design, size, or material.
You can even go back to the drawing board
completely and imagine something totally different
that could direct a descending rocket.
Can something other than grid fins be better
for the successor to the Falcon 9, Starship?
There were also questions related to Tesla,
as students had exposure to Tesla’s design
studio within SpaceX’s Hawthorne factory.
What could the supercharger network in a country
where it doesn’t yet exist?
What if you created a supercharger network
in Argentina?
There are many different ways to answer this
question.
What Josh was looking for was the ability
to reason.
Centering superchargers around dense populations
is a start.
And then the question is, “Where do we go
next?”
And the way that they reason through that
is really interesting because then they’re
seeing the multiple pathways they can approach.
And one of the ways you can help them is to
limit the number of superchargers they can
build.
So if you can only build 50 superchargers
in the country of Argentina for that first
year, where would those 50 be?
This is some high-level thinking at a young
age.
It’s remarkable what kids are capable of
when you give them opportunities where they
have decisions to make.
Josh now runs Synthesis, an online program
applying the same type of thinking at Elon’s
school.
Students from around the world strategize
in teams as a way to mirror collaboration
in real life.
We’ll start the first game in about five
minutes.
Although the students are as young as eight,
the problems they have to answer are difficult
even for adults.
For example: Imagine that rocket travel is
as normal as plane travel.
If you had to choose one future, which would
it be:
Traveling to anywhere on Earth within an hour
Going sightseeing on the moon
Or 3), starting a city on Mars
Again, there’s no right or wrong answer.
But the idea is to start wondering which will
come first, and which one will change human
life on earth most?
It’s about figuring out what the future
will look like.
And then, building that future.
In the way that Tesla is looking to disrupt
transportation, and SpaceX the rocket industry,
Elon is reimagining the future of education.
Although his original private school is no
longer running, he’s opened up another Ad
Astra school at SpaceX’s Starbase in Texas,
with a few dozen students.
Will this type of education produce the next,
great entrepreneur?
There are many ways to learn that can be more
effective than sitting in a classroom.
My sponsor, Brilliant, is a website and app
where you can improve your science, math,
and computer science skills by learning interactively.
Their puzzles are for people of all ages and
experiences - whether you’re studying or
if you’re already working.
I use Brilliant to improve my critical thinking
skills by going through their Logic courses.
Brilliant has sponsored my videos since I
started Newsthink in 2020, and I’ve noticed
my viewers especially love their Computer
Science Fundamentals course, where you can
wrap your mind around computational thinking
and no coding is required.
Their Scientific Thinking course is also really
popular with my viewers.
You can explore the
laws of physics and principles of engineering,
and learn the rules as you play.
If you’re ever stuck, you can view the explanation
to understand where you went wrong.
Brilliant is FREE for you to try out by going
to the custom link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people to sign up with my
link will get 20% off the annual Premium subscription,
which unlocks all of the courses on Brilliant.